Well, he thought that there are many people, although nothing
has been resolved, not even unemployment and
even immigrant people who do not have
work and unfortunately there are going to be
many people who are going to be left homeless.
I really feel that it could be more than
just until September.
After all, many people come without a mask, they
continue to exhibit, so it does not seem that this is
going to stop
at the nytimes, a wine, it is sad to
know that there are people affected, because some
do not do what they have to do despite,
so the one who does not work  it did not start
trying to do what we have done all our lives
I do not know if there is no work to
sell what can be done what
can be left more than anything families
stay together and where one eats
two eats so that is the only thing we can
do  It is to help each other
because the others are not going to help us. I
think it is to get on both sides of
both the owner and the rent because
both parties are being affected by
this pandemic, so it is considered  er to
both parties and reach an agreement to see
how both parties can
benefit because I think it is wrong
that they do that because it is not one
's fault, it is the government's fault, all
this in my way of thinking
and this virus  it comes and this is fixed
this is a government thing it is not something
that comes from other places it is things of d
or of all the governments that
agree for all that
if it is to get rid of so many
older people who are already unloading for the
government  they don't want to keep it anymore it's the
thing
like how well said it was and
people realized that
because the big ones no longer because they've already
started so also young people and all
that to cover it up a little bit the dad is there
to cover it up a little bit
we have to think about the problem
because the government is the one that has to
help a government that has the
obligation to help one because this
is not a matter of one person I repeat things
about him I think so if they have to
help the g  Because it's not the
fault of the people who lose their
jobs, organize, they can't be
evicted,
and the governor basically told them
when he
and they can start the evictions, and it depends
on what team it is, what type of
residence it is, if so, it's a street
like  in
these they start earlier and the reason
also what matters is the reason
why they want to evict so it's
just for not paying
that leaves the evictions you can't go
until September first that's when they
would start to perez that until September
first we can  to be evicted
just for not paying rent that does not
mean that they do not owe rent, yes, they will
owe what
is past rent, what lean words cannot do
is to put, for example, if
one does not stop their rent time  and there are
certain costs that add to the rent,
true, because those things cannot be
added because they do not pay at this time, they
can start lamas in September,
starting in September, so they
cannot  not pay for those past costs,
even though they have existed between March 30
and August 31, which is the time for you,
there is a moratorium, talk to that person
to see if they are available to
enter into any arrangement, let's go
before the eviction time begins to
make
given in September so if they know
that, for example, if they already lacked rent, they
should talk to the
owners right now to see if they
can enter into any arrangement,
the state is going to receive or has received 50
billion dollars, which is going to be
dedicated to helping people
who need help with their rent we
don't know exactly how
the money is going to be destroyed because they haven't
given the information about the process or the
application that is going to be given we hope to hear
something soon about that then still
We don't know what the qualifications are going to be
for the people who
can make them accept this help. It
's that for now it helps with paying for the
sale
[Music]
because nothing else is apart  e from the
anacafé organization
that there are already
companies that help, nothing else, I know that
there are churches that help with that type of
help or that give that type of help,
there are other non-profit companies that
also help the government
Right now we don't know when that help is going to be
given,
but I would also recommend that the first
thing they do is talk to the owner of the
property because they have the contract to
see what arrangements can be made before
requesting the help for two people
until September first,
like  I explained if it is just for non-payment
of rent they are protected and if there are
other reasons why they can
start evictions the first part
of August
but reasons are included for
example if they break the contract in another
way not only for not paying  but in another
way
or if they act in a way that is illegal
in the present property it may be others
are if there is not,
for example,
that they have broken the law or that they have
broken
the contract of  that of the is
camps
if this reason does not exist then the
dialogue can give us until September
first